In this section, we will learn about metahuman DNA.
For rig logic to work, it needs a metahuman DNA file.
Let's answer the question, what is metahuman DNA?
Metahuman DNA is a file format that stores the complete description of a 3D object's rig and geometry.
DNA files store only the faces of metahuman characters.
The data is separated into logical layers, and each layer depends on the previous one to make sense of the data.
At the top of the DNA file data layer is the descriptor.
This has information about the character that a DNA file is representing, such as the character's name.
Next is the definition. This tells us about the elements of the rig and how those are divided into LODs.
This has two layers, the behavior layer and the geometry layer.
The behavior layer is what makes a character unique and how it behaves when it is animated.
This is split into input and output.
The input is how the information maps from the faceboard controls to the raw controls that also trigger corrective expressions.
The output is how the joint attribute values are stored, how different LODs affect joint behavior,
and how the activation for each expression for blend shapes and animated maps is affected by LODs.
The geometry layer contains information about the mesh, the skinning, and corrective blend shapes.
This includes information about the topology and vertex position of meshes and skinning information such as the values of weights for each vertex of every mesh.
This is why when making modifications to the neutral pose, those changes need to be updated in the DNA file.
We have just gone over what metahumanDNA is.
In the next section we will look at the DNA calibration repository and how we can use this to make adjustments to the neutral pose and update the metahumanDNA file.